good afternoon NDC how are you all doing
[Laughter]
2019 marks a historic anniversary in the
endeavours of human engineering 50 years
ago 1969 Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin
became the first human beings ever to
walk on another world and as we
celebrate the 50th anniversary of the
the moon landings and the culmination of
the Apollo program we thought this would
be a good opportunity to look back at
some of the techniques and processes
that were developed as part of that
program small steps giant leaps
engineering lessons from Apollo now I
care first had this idea well what we
are not going to do today is tell you
how the software that flew to the moon
actually worked there is a couple of
good reasons one it ran on a 2.0
megahertz processor with 32 words of 15
bit memory plus one bit for parity
because you have problems in space with
radiation and stuff and the source code
for Apollo 11 the spacecraft that flew
to the moon is actually on github you
can go up there and you can read it one
of NASA's interns scanned it all in a
couple years ago they put it online
there's a couple of very good pull
requests if you fancy a laugh there's
one which is a change to the mission
profile to go and rescue Matt Damon from
Mars there is one which is a it was
actually quite sort of subtle someone
made a change to one of the
configuration timing files and it took a
couple of days before they realized that
they'd fixed the thing that crippled
Apollo 13 in a pull request 48 years too
late so you know software engineering
deadlines you got this but a few years
ago I had the the great pleasure of
going to the Science Museum here in
London to watch these two gentlemen
Brian
and Colonel Buzz Aldrin talking
about space travel and it was a really
brilliant session in Buzz Aldrin is is
in his 80s now and he's still working
full-time on you know human crude
spaceflight and something that kind of
came across really strongly in his
conversation as part of this interview
and a lot of the work he does is a sense
of frustration that we were better at
this in the 1960s than we are now and to
some extent he's right
you know in the 1970s if the United
States of America wanted to fly to space
they put one of their space rockets
there fueled it up and went and now if
the United States wants to go into space
they have to get a lift with the
Russians or ask Elon Musk for a favor
they are working on it I understand but
you know this sort of started me
thinking I wonder how much of the stuff
that the techniques and processes and
technology that was developed for the
Apollo moon landings and you know like
Buzz Aldrin's mission here I don't know
how much of that is still relevant and I
wonder if there's really stuff in there
that we used to be good at that we have
forgotten so I started putting together
this idea for a kind of 50th anniversary
of the moon landings talk and then I was
at build stuff in the theater last year
I was looking on the program and I saw
1968 I talked bike Evelyn Haney and I
thought bug Evelyn has beaten me to it
he has nicked my idea so I went along to
Kevin's talk and it was brilliant and it
was all about stuff we got right in the
1960s that a lot of companies and
organizations are still struggling with
today and to my great relief it was not
about space travel but I happen to know
that Kevin is a huge space nerd just
like me and so I was trying to after I
said look I got this idea for a thing I
want to do next year would you be
interested in in collaborating doing it
together and he said yes so please give
a big hand welcome to the stage Kevin
Henny
I just like to blame the Lithuanian beer
it accepts full responsibility yes right
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
a launch countdown we are gonna share
with you ten lessons from eleven eleven
the hole goes all the way up to eleven
the others this is the spinal tap
mission profile we have eleven lessons
from eleven observations from the Apollo
moon landings and the sort of you know
though the pioneering period in manned
space aviation starting with number ten
strategy vision and roadmap now at the
beginning of the 1960's right America
was in a bit of a pickle it was you know
they call but not in all this the world
war two had ended but the Cold War was
kinda you know very much underway there
was this this war of kind of minds and
propaganda and things going on between
the United States and the Soviet Union
and in 1958 the Soviet Union had shocked
the entire world by launching this
Sputnik one the first ever artificial
satellite and and you know this was a
few people realized they were even close
to being able to do this and in terms of
the impact that this had on the world
people in the United States could go
outside with a shortwave radio just in
their backyard and they could hear a
Russian satellite flying over the
mainland u.s. there's a journalist at
the site who said it doesn't matter
whether you believe it or not you can go
in your backyard at sunset and look at
it and you know this scared a lot of
people it caused a lot of you know sort
of very complicated political
maneuvering and how is the u.s. going to
respond to this and their first
satellite launched wasn't much of a
success what's now no they there's lots
of really good footage of exploding
rockets a lot of the exploding rocket
stuff that you get black-and-white
footage that's that's kind of these
early launches a lovely kaputnik is
there what the press dubbed the first
American at
to put a satellite in orbit and but they
they did eventually succeed they got
Explorer one in orbit a few months after
this and then the Soviets got another
first with Yuri Gagarin the first human
being to go into 12th of April 1961
which for the date watch's 12th of April
1981 was the first launch of the space
shuttle if you're trying to get a sense
of the how much you can do in 20 years
but yeah he went into orbit them how was
that I love the fact they commemorate
Gagarin everyone else get you know
Columbus Day and Martin Luther King gate
he gets Yuri's Night because you
commemorate Gagarin's flight by going
outside at night and looking up at the
stars which i think is quite cool and
again the United States followed suit
but there was very much this perception
that they were playing catch up they
were getting left behind in the space
race now we're here to talk today about
the engineering behind the moon landings
but it's important to understand the
fundamental objective of any engineering
project somewhere somebody would have
something that they are trying to do
something they are trying to achieve the
u.s. did not you know President Kennedy
and his advisors they didn't care about
the moon there's nothing on the moon
that they particularly wanted they
needed a way of scoring points in this
propaganda war and this is a memorandum
from 1961 sent from President Kennedy to
his Vice President Lyndon Johnson where
he literally says do we have a chance of
beating the Soviets by putting a
laboratory in space or by a trip around
the middle by a rocket to land on the
moon or a rocket to go to the moon and
back with a man is there any other space
program which promises dramatic results
which we could win so this is just over
a week after Gagarin goes into orbit and
so there this is the kind of response
time oh but look at the ambition that's
already laid out we don't know what but
we need something and it's all it's got
moon it's got laboratory it's got the
works okay so in other words they
weren't just thinking of should we
should we just put a couple of people in
orbit and do something clever with them
there's no no the moon was genuinely
outrageously a possibility and and you
know the thing that I think is
interesting about this there's like okay
here is our objective this is the sowing
I think about is the what and how what
do we need to do impress the Soviets
impress the world how we got a bunch of
options let's pick one when you pick one
that
comes the what the decision is made and
then leadership and management is how do
you communicate that decision above and
beyond the increases I had earlier
requested for space activities to
provide the funds which are needed to
meet the following national goals first
I believe that this nation should commit
itself to achieving the goal before this
decade is out of landing a man on the
moon and returning him safely to the
earth
no single space project in this period
will be more impressive to mankind or
more important for the long-range
exploration of space and none will be so
difficult or expensive to accomplish I
just want to take a moment to pick apart
this quote because this is one of the
sort of great historic speeches of the
last century I believe that this nation
should commit itself this is not a
mission being assigned to somebody else
some organization this is the President
of the United States saying this nation
should commit itself we are all in this
together to achieving the goal before
this decade is out now that it sounds
good doesn't it it's like good thumping
rhetoric at this point
the United States they had what 15
minutes 15 minutes in space total that
was they sent someone up above Florida
and he's splashed back into the sea they
had no idea how I guess so that's Alan's
shirt but that's and that was it that's
you're going to go from 15 minutes to
the moon and you're gonna go and ask for
money you are but look at the framing of
this now the CIA believed that the
Russians the Soviet Union would not be
able to land on the moon before 1970 so
this kind of classic quote is actually a
really calculated estimate this is we
need as much time as we've got as much
time as we can possibly by ourselves to
do this but if we take too long the
whole thing is pointless because they're
going to get there first before this
decade is out of landing a man on the
moon and returning him safely to the
earth
now there was talk at the time why don't
we send someone on a one-way trip
and a lot of the the early astronauts
you know these were military test pilots
who had served in World War two served
in Korea they were absolutely used to
the idea that people died in the service
of their country by putting this other
thing that was taken off the table
President Kennedy is like no you know
this is the equivalent of one of your
engineering meant of saying satting I'm
saying look we need to make money we are
not going to sell our customer data stop
talking about that that is not an option
here
in how we are trying to solve this
problem and that was it you know this
the vision was stated now there is some
language here that I want to pick up on
and dig into a little bit because you
see the word man come up an awful lot we
talked about manned space like landing a
man on the moon one small step for a man
and there is a certain kind of school of
commentary which says our that's just
how people talked in the 1960s that was
inclusive language I'm calling
on that because if America really wanted
to put human beings on the moon there
are quite a lot of human beings who
consume less than men in terms of the
amount of food and water and oxygen that
is required to keep them alive for the
duration of the mission on average they
tend to weigh less they're known as
women if America really wanted to get to
the moon first they would have sent a
female crew on Apollo but they didn't
there was you know there was some
consideration there was consideration so
in other words this is not just
retrospective at the time there was
discussion genuine proper consideration
parallel programs this was all all
explored
considered but it is and so anyone says
it's institutionalized language that's
not institutionalized sexism is what it
was but you know this was a long time
ago but I just I wanted to pick that up
we are going to be using man a lot
because that's what's in all the quotes
we're discussing and the documents and
so on
we wanted to put some context around it
now when somebody on one of your teams
communicates a big decision it takes a
little while and then people start going
we're not sure about this this is
expensive this doesn't make sense we
don't like it we should have used
MongoDB
leadership is often as much about
following through it's not just making
the decision it is being prepared to
reinforce to defend that decision 18
months later Congress are starting to
complain about how much money is being
spent on the moon program they haven't
kind of no return on that investment yet
and Kennedy is at Rice University he
makes this historic good most no
prejudice no national conflict in outer
space as yet its hazards are hostile to
us all its conquest deserves the best of
all mankind and its opportunity for
peaceful cooperation may never come
again but why some say the moon why
choose this as our goal and they may
we'll ask why climb the highest mountain
why 35 years ago fly the Atlantic why
does Rice play Texas we choose to go to
the moon we choose to go to the moon
[Applause]
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other things not
because they are easy but because they
are hard because that goal will serve to
organize and measure the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is one that we are willing to
accept one we are unwilling to postpone
and one we intend to win and the others
too
so just in case you'd forgotten what a
president can sound like now as you know
Kennedy did not live to see his vision
fulfilled he was assassinated at what 18
months after that at Dallas Texas
November 1963 but that vision you know
at its peak the Apollo moon program
employed something like half a million
people and every single one of them knew
that speech there's a story about Lyndon
Johnson who became president after
Kennedy's assassination going to visit a
NASA facility and as just a guy mopping
the floor and he goes over and he says
hey you know what are you doing and this
janitor looks up from his mop and he
says mr. president I'm helping put a man
on the moon and you know you think about
that level of alignment behind the goal
of your organization how many people are
on your teams and in the companies you
work with could you go and say what are
you working on and straightaway they're
like we're trying to do this this is
what we're trying to do this is what
we're working towards we're all gonna
know when we've done it and on that day
every single one of us is gonna feel
like we were part of this accomplishment
we were part of this victory which leads
us nicely into people now it's quite
initially it's obvious that you think of
the astronauts you think of the right
stuff and a lot of people think that it
is just simply that they were
accomplished flight jocks from square
jaws there's a little bit more than that
they certainly fitted a certain photo
profile but they were not necessarily
beautiful but what was interesting is
when you look at them they had a
particular passion the Armstrong had
wanted to do this kind of things
they all wanted to go to space they
monstrous yeah he had a pilot's license
before he had a driver's license he
passed his pilot's license on his 16th
birthday with the money he saved working
in a drugstore you know so there so
there's a dedication here we have and
they went and they weren't simply just
Flyboys the to this day NASA is still
using techniques that Buzz Aldrin worked
on in his doctrine in 1963 about
honestly how do you how do you dock
craft in orbit orbital alignment the
visual alignment everything this was all
explored so he got his doctorate for
that so anyone in here played Kerbal
space program yeah you know how
difficult it is yeah Aldrin wrote his
doctoral thesis in 1963 on had a wooden
Kerbal space program yeah basically so
you know he's got the job and so you've
got so you ready to discover them the
people are actually going to be on the
mission are already over qualified in
one sense but it goes all the way down
this is gene Krantz and Center you know
if you wash the place they're taking
place very key role there gets a new
waistcoat for every mission so in high
school he had written his thesis on
interplanetary travel you know goes all
the way back this is not just a
recruitment what do you well do you know
what would you like to do I don't know
I've just been working for some company
and this looked like a good opportunity
to change career no it's just like
there's a dedication there's a focus
because all the way down so you've got
you've got you you're looking for geeks
you're looking for the right kind of gig
and let's have a look at some 1960s
geeks so this is illustrates the
diversity of NASA in the 1960s this
gentleman here is smoking a pipe the
rest of them are smoking cigarettes this
was a diverse workforce but they're all
wearing the standard uniform which is
the white shirt with the pence okay so
you know you knew you knew that these
people could be trusted but there is a
notion here and I think it's very easy
to forget when you're looking bad yeah
we got much better computers on the rest
of it but computers only allow you to do
something faster and more easily
have to have something else there the
people thing that kind of focus and that
is the right people thing where if you
if you have doesn't matter what your
compilers doing doesn't mean you're
gonna get good code it doesn't matter if
you are if you come to NDC and you go to
a talking you say I'm going to take back
all of the buzzwords and that's people
caught yeah we this is how we do we're
gonna invest in this and we will learn
how to do it and work together on this
now
there is a little bit it wasn't just
yeah wasn't just opposed history is not
very good at recording this but yes
there were women mathematicians almost
just we're almost in the classic
computer era in the sense that women
were the people who actually computed
all this stuff with just a little bit
after the hidden figures here we've not
seen here figures that's definitely
worth watching but there is this notion
that you have four hundred thousand
people and there is a pyramid here but
everybody fits all the way down to the
janitor and there is a certain passion
and dedication one of the the
interesting things they did is they
would send the astronauts on tours of
the workplaces so they'd go to like a
rubber factory in Delaware and one of
these people who they'd seen on TV they
see on Life magazine would basically
stand up and say do good work or we're
gonna die and all these people would go
back to work on a production line you
know gluing rubber seals for helmet
colors and things thinking if we do our
job right that man's going to land on
the moon and if we do our job wrong he's
gonna die and it might be our fault it
was an incredibly effective way of kind
of mobilizing the right people and
getting them all aligned behind these
these kinds of objects but we're not
suggesting that you go motivate people
through threats of death okay it's just
understanding with respect to this
project that was the appropriate
alignment take any opportunity you can
to remind people why what you're doing
matters sort of that Rockets so yeah the
consider approach we're going to
consider approaches and make decisions
we see there is the classic Tintin in
fact well this is taken from Tintin but
this is the classic rocket this is what
people recognize as a rocket and this is
the rocket of the 1950s the 1960s and
honestly even after a poor landed this
is still
people's kind of default mental models
now there's an interesting thing here is
that this is my large it it flies from
the earth all the way to the moon and
then comes all the way back turns out
that takes quite a lot of fuel and it
turns out on the pages of a comic book
that doesn't really matter and with the
special effects of the time you can make
a film and it doesn't really matter so
we mentioned earlier this idea we need
to impress the you know press the world
beat the Russians how this way this way
this way this way pick that one go with
it once they decided to go to the moon
how there were a bunch of options on the
table these were the basically the the
high level mission profiles they could
have flown now Tintin's rocket there is
what is known as a direct ascent take a
great big rocket launch it off the earth
fly it to the moon land it on the moon
launch it off the moon fly it back to
the earth and land again the two
alternatives that were being considered
and developed were something called the
Earth orbit rendezvous you launch a
bunch of components into orbit around
the Earth you stick them together and
then you fly that to the moon and land
it and the third one which is outside it
wasn't it like no seriously at first was
a thing called that the lunar orbit
rendezvous where you basically you park
one ship in orbit around the moon and
you send the other piece down and they
walk around on the moon then they come
back and they dock and you bring the
whole thing the whole thing back to
earth again and and we got a sort of
illustration from some blueprints of the
time ever this is the size of the thing
that would have had to land on the moon
and come make it back to the earth so
and the one on the left that's the bit
on the top looks familiar doesn't yeah
I've seen those before so in other words
there are parts of the design they're
already kind of settled but what you've
now got is this effective support system
for taking the earth return vehicle all
the way down to the service surface if
you're not going to use it and then
taking it all the way back up again and
all the way back to earth alternatively
the lunar the lunar orbit approach it's
just like just so now the lander we
specialize different stages of the
journey and in fact what they ended up
with was effectively a hybrid of
a little bit rendezvous and the lunar
rendezvous in the earth or the one in
fact if you watch it will be referred to
Apollo 13 the film later if you watch
there's this notion there the term lunar
injection or there's all of this kind of
stuff they orbited the earth are we good
are we good yes we're good right we're
ready to go and so in other words each
stage of the mission is carried out it
has its own as it were it's a sub
mission and you can actually explore it
quite nicely quite tightly and it turns
out that indirection is helpful it also
helped the engineer excise things as we
can see here so one of the disadvantages
of the direct ascent approaches as we've
already mentioned you have to carry
everything with you the fuel that you
are not going to need until you get back
to the earth and you're decelerating to
come and splashdown you need to carry
that fuel all the way to the moon and
all the way back with all of the
logistics and complexity in that that
entails now how many of you have ever
kicked off a software project by doing
NPM install and suddenly you have 200
modules that you're not going to need
until you actually go live six months
later or you know you do kind of like a
big design up front and you just end up
on the way you're developing software
with this friction you're carrying this
enormous amount of complexity production
databases deployment processes
encryption keys which are not helping
you get where you need to go and you're
not gonna need them right until the very
end basically you know you want to take
some lessons from the the mission
profiles about how to build software
when you install packages imagine that
they're made of thousands of tons of
explosive rocket fuel and ask yourself
do you want to be carrying that with you
every time you try and do anything
because the more whether it's it's you
know physical mass on a spacecraft or
it's just complexity of any kind of
engineering project the more complexity
you're carrying with you the harder it
is to change your mind about what you're
going to do next the harder it is to
pivot and to change their and that's
that reduction of complexity that is
really important in it because what
you'll seeing is again it's the that big
upfront design thing where you can end
up carrying literally this design weight
all the way through let us design for
all of the requirements that we imagine
at this point but we haven't delivered
anything and there is that notion of
like no lettuce
create this mission in two different
parts this mission profile has different
stages different stories are going to be
told we can isolate each one of these
explore it and it carries no more weight
than necessary there's a conceptual
elegance to that there are and there's
also this kind of thing about try try a
couple things out and practice good
found this wonderful one it's what would
the consequence of the direct ascent
approach be well it means that the
actual astronaut compartment is way way
off the ground and when you first look
at this it looks like it's guys just
hanging on for dear life hanging out
what is actually looks like a Gemini
capsule it's just hanging on and then
you look closely you realize there's
little footholds this is a really the
first thing you've got to do is climb
down an insane client if you're a
climber then you know this is this is ok
you think that's quite an interesting
challenge but you're wearing a spacesuit
and you've now got to walk get down to
the surface via well this is multiple
stories so there are issues with this
design not least in which is now I look
at it closely there's no way for them to
get back up that all returning them
safely to the earth
so instead on the right hand side there
it is it's and again there's another
modularity aspect here is that the
return part is the upper stage so that
even this is in two stages and they have
the material here is incredibly fragile
it is it's not much better than
aluminium foil this thing is definitely
not designed for the turbulence of Earth
reentry so this is a very delicate thing
it was designed for a purpose and again
there's a modularity lesson here as well
something else they discovered is that
you can source this out to different
people now we'll be coming back to the
consequences of cycle later so counting
down seven so work towards significant
master that's that's a Gemini capsule no
that is
so the programs through the u.s.
programs Mercury Gemini Apollo mercury
one astronaut Gemini two astronauts
looks a bit like a mercury capsule just
a little bit larger
Apollo three astronauts but what was
interesting is going back to Kennedy's
speech and this question of feasibility
how are you going to do this thing that
nobody has ever done before but it turns
out it's made up of lots of different
things that people have never done
before to only go where no one has gone
before quite literally so there's all of
this stuff and it turns out what they
did they broke down the objectives each
mission was basically designed to
demonstrate something in hardware in
software in human terms or in terms of
the actual structure of how are we going
to get this stuff done a very simple one
a very simple example is we've never
sent two people into orbit okay that's
the first thing
and what about docking turns out that's
quite a big deal if you plan to dock in
orbit first of all around the earth and
then again around the moon it turns out
you need to know how to dock you can't
just leave that one you need to practice
this you need to find out how that works
and this didn't go as quite as well as
planned initially and Neil Armstrong was
the survivor he managed to survive a
mission but docking with thena module
that turned out to be more exciting than
was expected but this is why you did
each thing how do you go outside a
spacecraft that was ed white how do you
do all these things every single one and
the whole the Apollo program is
structured like that it was really weird
quirk so the Gemini program every one of
them so so Gemini one was the first to
put two people into orbit Gemini two was
the first mission to use a hydrogen fuel
cell Gemini three four five Gemini 7
launched before Gemini 6 because Gemini
6 was gonna test rendezvous and it
didn't have anything to rendezvous with
so they had to launch Gemini 7 first so
that six could go up and dock with it
yes it's not just stars films that are
out of sequence but this is important
and importantly that that was a
rendezvous of
- manned spacecraft they'd already tried
docking as well so in other words this
is they're not coming to each one of you
they were there they're upping it
because that's the other thing is when
they when they rendezvous from the lunar
return from the lunar surface you have
humans in one craft you have humans in
the other craft so every single thing is
like can't we figure out this one can we
do this and the point is when they
figured it out they did it they shipped
it every single one of these missions
was like we've tested it in a lab we
talk more about simulation testing in a
minute they did it they put real people
in space doing a real mission profiles
to prove this stuff was actually gonna
work six so this is it turns out and you
might be familiar with the idea of names
being hard but it also matters
maybe things matters and all the way
down to NASA which had a very unsexy
name in the nice and 50s but you can
imagine if you left it to most
government organizations you'd end up
with a very dull name and a very dull
logo this is actually quite dynamic but
on the right you see the patch for
Apollo 11 and you have the image of the
eagle the eagle was callsign that Aldrin
and Armstrong used and this whole idea
of the call signs being used was really
quite important we can actually see
there's a there's a couple of things
here one is there's a sort of an
emotional aspect to the name there's a
personal connection there you have the
name Apollo which is far more evocative
you're tapping into Greek mythology
there we compare that with some of the
names they've got now like ISS and SLS
and stuff like that so these names are
the things that people remember okay so
let's let's talk about something that
you won't remember one six one nine six
905 C has landed daddy won't remember
that one that famous quote no that's the
official that's the official designation
of that vehicle in fact if you go to the
NASA page that's you look at the URL
that is um we could go a little bit
further and get a little bit more of a
name Apollo 11 LM EAS
EP has landed so the /ln lunar module
EAS EP now that's the experimental
package it was the early prototype an
experimental package they kind of grid
of stuff that is on the moon again
that's an official designation and then
you get this and you think yeah history
remembers this one right from
tranquility base tranquility base was
something that Aldrin and Armstrong made
up they yeah the first time anybody ever
heard it was when they set it here
except for Charlie Duke who was Capcom
we'll talk about Capcom later who
briefed he was briefed by Aldrin and
Armstrong we're gonna call it
tranquility a tranquility base just so
you're not faced when we say it okay so
you're primed the eagle has landed so
you've got all of this you've got this
language here this is this is this is
shows a connection the people who are
doing the work to their work these are
not simple numbers but these are also
things from the public perception
there's something joyful about one of
the great things about the names is that
it was the the crews who actually flew
on the ships who got to choose the names
for them that kind of up to a point so
Apollo 8 was when it arrived when the
command module arrived from it was
Rockwell engineering wasn't yes Rockwell
it was wrapped in the polythene look
like a giant boiled sweet so they called
it gumdrop and then the the lunar module
was called spina was gonna be called
spider didn't actually fly so gumdrop
and spider were the call signs for that
one and then the one after that all the
astronauts wore these little kind of
cloth caps with little black earpieces
which is where they had their
communication scale it made them look
like Snoopy and so they adopted Snoopy
and Charlie Brown as the kind of
unofficial mascots of the Apollo program
and Apollo 10 which was the one that
nearly land or you know was a full dress
rehearsal and was called that the
command module was Charlie Brown and the
lunar module was Snoopy and if they'd
landed it would have been Houston
tranquility base here snooping has
landed on the moon you know one small
step for a beagle one giant at which
point NASA was like you can you can
still pick the names but please pick
slightly better sounding names but you
know that led to the sense of this is
our mission we get to choose even the
mission patches we got the backtrack a
couple of slides yeah so that the Apollo
11 mission patch which is the the
American Eagle with the olive branch of
peace landing on the moon with the earth
in the background it was designed by
Neil Armstrong it wasn't some art
department the cruise designed their own
mission insignia their own call signs
and that you know when you trust the
engineers to be like looking you're
working on this thing what do you want
to call it
what name makes sense for your project
that's gonna give you that sense of of
ownership and investment in the way that
you relate to the machines and the
systems that you're building it can make
a massive difference that costs you know
almost nothing five away on five four
five five yes so we're gonna take a
systems view and this is Margaret
Hamilton she was she headed up the team
at MIT that developed the Apollo
guidance computer the software for the
Apollo guidance computer and that
software what ran on both the command
module and on the lunar module and as
stiller mentioned earlier are the
constraints of memory were quite
ridiculous but she was also the person
that coined the term software
engineering but she the most famous
picture of her I think we have a picture
of the code we have a picture of the
code there she is next to the code but
she is also immortalized who by the way
who has the Lego women of NASA oh come
on people you can do better than that
you know we have two in our house
so she's one of the women of NASA but
notice the fidelity of the of this
observe preparing the tool they even
kept the hat standing the hats then
they've got the same code written up on
the blackboard and they've got this this
stack of folders which is all so that
the github slide I showed you at the
beginning these are the folders which
were scanned in and then corrected by
hand to put that repository up on github
that's how much code they had to put in
to share that repo so what it looked
like hard copy and they didn't have a
compiler most of this was
compile is hand compiled if you've ever
wondered about that's a hand compiled
you're thinking incrementally compiled
Rosa so they did it hand compiled is
exactly as it sounds
artisanal coat weaving ones and zeros on
two little ferrite core memory rings
with copper wire by hand and doing it
just right otherwise the nice man who
came to the factory last week might die
and it'll be your fault
that's what this quote so here's this
thing invented the term software she as
she says here I began to use the term
sovereign genius to distinguish it from
harbor and other kinds of engineering
yet each tree each type of engineering
is part of the overall systems
engineering process what I find
fascinating about this one is there's a
lot of misunderstandings over the
terminology and the term and what it
means but what she was trying to say is
there's a there's a seat at the table
software was not as well considered back
then but as we can see they did some
fairly serious work her work will come
back to we'll come back to fault
tolerance a little bit later and one of
her design decisions that turns out of
basically save the mission but notice
there's this idea this is parity there
are systems engineering we're gonna take
a systems view there are so many things
to coordinate and software engineers
simply one of them and this is what is
this systems view so what does it wants
to encompass so here we have so the
service and command module were
developed by Rockwell and if you just
look through all the bits and pieces
here you suddenly realize if you start
counting the number of disciplines
there's a parachute up at the top that's
your classic aerospace okay but the
material science here is not classic
aerospace so you're dealing with
materials science you're dealing with
chemistry you are dealing with
electrical engineering you've obviously
got the software component when you
start running through it you saw you
think this is this is incredibly
multidisciplinary it's very easy that we
take the encapsulated view of the
capsule and just say yeah it's just
hardware actually what they were having
to do was to take this huge view and
then integrate it with guess what turns
out that if you have module so you can
have other companies build and so this
was built by Rockwell but the lunar
module was I think grummons it was
grooming yeah so
that I think we have a slide yeah there
we are
so that was built by a separate
contractor there but this software the
Apollo guidance computer was the same
the software running on that so it turns
out that there's a there's a level of
communication here but I think we
underestimate but then how big is a
system turns out the system's can be
very very large one of them they were
systems thinking they were systems
thinking one of the challenges that NASA
encountered is first flight 15 minutes
up in Florida down in the ocean no
problem put someone in orbit they're
like oh hang on America's gonna be on
the wrong side of the earth for half of
this mission and so they built a global
network of tracking stations there's a
Zelan seen the movie the dish it's this
movie about the Parkes radio telescope
in Australia which was this this massive
in a radio telescope dish in the middle
of the outback which happened to be the
dish that was pointing at the moon when
Apollo 11 arrived and landed there and
you know it's a great movie lovely movie
yeah but it also kind of gives you some
insight into they didn't just run
everything out of houston they had to
think about the entire you know the
entire planet as they're sort of a
sphere of operations no pun intended and
there's this lovely quote Frank Borman
who was one of the first people to fly
around the moon on Apollo 8 first time
human beings had ever seen the Earth
from deep space when you're finally up
at the moon looking back on earth all
those differences and nationalistic
traits are pretty well gonna blend and
you're gonna get a concept that maybe
this really is one world and why the
hell can't we learn to live together
like decent people so that systems
thinking bigger picture it doesn't get
much bigger for standard I some people
recognize this I can hear little giggles
in the audience we're gonna show you a
clip so that the movie Apollo 13 a Ron
Howard film made in the 90s about the
13th Apollo mission which famously ran
into all kinds of difficulty and Apollo
13 has been celebrated for its
historical accuracy there's this this
lovely quote they asked Jim Lovell who
was the commander they said you know how
much of the film did they make up and he
said they got pretty much everything
right except the dialogue they had to
like invent a little bit of Frick
character development because if you
listen to the transcripts we weren't
arguing we were just getting on with the
mission
you know but generally Apollo 13 is is
celebrated for being as accurate as it
could possibly be and this is a scene
from that movie situation growing like
that carbon dioxide we got to see a to
filter problem on the lunar module five
filters on the limb which we meant for
two guys for a day and a half so I told
the doctor they're already up to eight
on the gauges anything over 15 and you
get paired judgment blackouts the
beginnings of brain asphyxia about the
scrubbers on the command module it takes
quite cartridges ones on the limb around
tell me this isn't a government
operation it's just isn't a contingency
we can remotely looked at oh co2 levels
are gonna be getting toxic well I
suggest you gentlemen invent a way to
put a square peg in a round hole to make
this fit into the hole for this using
nothing but that now how many of you
worked on a software project that had
more than one login server how many it
wasn't pretty had more than one login
system we encounter this idea of you
know standardization it crops up time
and time again in the way that we work
in engineer I've lost a slide here hang
on there we go - back back back back
back there we go
thank you PowerPoint NASA did not use
PowerPoint they use those old-fashioned
overhead things with anyway um the
problem they had here in the scene from
Apollo 13 that a solve a problem human
beings exhale carbon dioxide which is
toxic you need a way to remove it from
the air that they are breathing that's
the problem they solve the same
in two different ways because it was
solved by two different companies
building two different components of the
system the people building the lunar
module solved the problem we need a way
of removing carbon dioxide from there
they use the thing called lithium
hydroxide you run an air across it
absorbs the co2 you get breathable air
back out the other side
command module exactly the same problem
same solution lithium hydroxide one of
them had this big square canister one
had a round canister now what happened
with Apollo 13 the main spacecraft was
crippled they had to use the lunar
module as a lifeboat so you had three
people surviving for about 12 days in a
craft that was designed to support two
people for three days so they ran out of
canisters and they couldn't use the
spares because they were the wrong shape
because they were built for a different
system now this is not about redundancy
they had plenty of canisters this is
about they solved the same problem in
two different ways and the reason they
did it is probably our old friend
Conway's law now a lot of the times on
software systems when you find the same
problem has been solved in two different
ways you've got two different login
systems two different ORM is running in
different parts of the platform two
different you know data centers or
something it'll be because a team that
built one of them for whatever reason
they couldn't communicate because of
politics because of you know Geographic
barriers just maybe because one team was
five years ago and the other team was
last year they were not able to
communicate and so they build a system
who you know as Conway says it the
design of the system is constrained by
the communication structures of the
organization that created it now in
software this is just a pain in the ass
you've got two different login systems
two sets of keys to rotate on Apollo 13
this was very very nearly you know a
matter of life and death and that scene
that we just saw that was actually the
inspiration for the show scrapheap
challenged the people behind that show
saw this and they went they had to solve
this problem using only a certain you
know number of components they had to
improvise and stuff maybe we could do
something similar with that but you know
look out for those kind of patterns if
you have to solve a problem try and come
up with a single solution to that
problem that you can deploy everywhere
that that you know occurs and that
simplicity is also something else as
well and sometimes even within the same
system even with
the assistance of Conway's law we have a
habit of handcraft and complexity
without realizing that that was optional
we could have designed against it and so
although not the part of the Apollo
program it's certainly an aerospace
lesson that a good example of this is
something like the way that Boeing built
their aircraft up until the Boeing
triple7 all the aircraft all the doors
on an aircraft were different shapes so
that basically means one aircraft has
multiple different checks you have to
create you have to design create and
test they are not interchangeable then
you say well that's because the hull is
a different shape you know the back it
tapers different universe to me yes but
who designed the hull shape you had
control over that so it turns out that
one of the simple innovations of the
triple7 was let's let's create it so
that we can use the same doors we have a
standard door that will work and we know
it works on all these conditions they
won't be surprise elements there won't
be these edge cases because we're going
to design it so that we can encompass it
okay you know as they move towards
something that could be standardized
they said well rather than could be it
will be and this is a this is a deeper
less was it a southwestern airlines and
then Ryanair yeah who took this to the
extreme every single aircraft that
Ryanair fly is the same aircraft so
Boeing must feel like the same aircraft
it's not very well kitted out but yeah
three servants because that way every
pilot they have on their entire fleet
can fly all of their aircraft all of
their ground crew can maintain all of
their aircraft all their technicians
there's no edge cases it's all the same
you know I just occurred to me that the
phrase snowflake engineering there's a
reason that's not a term that you ever
hear okay so that the slides thankfully
have already counted down to the next
item on our list which is simulation
testing you gotta test this stuff now
how do you test going to the moon how do
you test walking on the moon how do you
test mm-hmm yes now NASA were very very
good at coming up with interesting ways
of simulating procedures in unfamiliar
environments we have a little montage
thanks to NASA
public domain video archives this is how
you rehearse for walking in lunar
gravity lunar gravity is one-sixth of
Earth's so therefore you've got to angle
this just like your right to support
that and the effective force here's one
safe notice yeah you go you know it kind
of looks if you look at the images from
the the moon walks yeah it's about the
same kind of dynamic although it's
somewhat more elegant so this was a
aircraft called kc-135 they call it the
vomit comet and it flies these big
parabolic dives so you get about 30 40
seconds of freefall and every single
thing they tested food in freefall to
make sure that the crumbs didn't drift
away they tested the drinks containers
they tested the toilets every detail
that was gonna fly in zero gravity and
for evey A's extra vehicular activity
spacewalks they tested it in huge water
tanks they would literally build
replicas of the spacecraft and the
systems underwater they'd get on there
in a spacesuit if you look for these by
the way you find so many clips on
YouTube of people going NASA faked the
moon landings look you can see the
bubbles and you're like no but there's a
really important point here with with a
lot of this stuff is that you're seeing
and this is a point that we should be
able to take into our workplace testing
requires creativity
ok there's this idea of like that you
want everything you know how do I test
this it's impossible to test that we
won't test it well no it's not
impossible it's just perhaps it's not a
technique that you've thought of is
perhaps not something you come across
and you know that standard mocking
framework that you're using perhaps
didn't think about the special case that
you're working be creative good testing
requires creativity and there's a
certain delight in some of that there
are actually pictures of the astronauts
astronauts the Apollo astronaut sitting
in the pool just you know practicing
being yeah we've done the main practice
they're just lying there in the Sun
that's practice doing nothing in space
yeah and that actually that that is a
skill this is the flying bedstead which
was used for the lunar landing and they
had they went through more than one Neil
Armstrong was
likely to survive crash with one but it
was there's a notion here of getting the
sense of what is it actually like to fly
this and trying to get as close as
possible as we say ingenuity is
necessary yeah one of the fascinating
things about their approach to
simulation so you think about you know
software system where you've got all
these complexities you've got usability
you've got accessibility you've got
performance you've got scalability and
we often think of you know the idea of
having a staging environment or
something think about it with a NASA
perspective can you create an
environment where you're not too worried
about usability and stuff what you're
doing is you're testing how your
application scales and how many of you
have got a primary key that's in an
integer column in one of your databases
come on a software conference this is
everybody what are you going to do if
you get 32 billion customers is it is it
gonna overflow yeah well it will it will
it overflow or will it just wrap around
and come out negative and what is your
code gonna do if it gets a customer with
a customer idea of minus 32 billion you
know these are all edge cases which are
very very hard to test as part of an
integrated test suite but it's very very
easy to just spin up a copy of the code
3 to do increment increment whoa I
didn't know it was gonna do that so if
anybody needs to make a phone call or
this point or just announced on 31
billion on something just you can excuse
you for a few minutes so all right we
are nearly at a liftoff to so this is
this is an interesting one no matter how
hard you test no matter how creative you
are and I'm just trying to explore the
scenarios there is always something that
will come up that will surprise you and
one of the classics is to the 1202 error
so there's two kinds of space nerds
there's people who like rockets and
there's people who know what a 1202
alarm is what's a 1202 alarm Kimberlin
right well these two this goes right
back to Margaret Halton it goes back to
the the executive for the AGC softly
Apollo gods computer software the spec
of that hardware was minimal if you're
landing you need to do a lot you've got
a single core almost no memory and there
are
we'll toss so basically it kind of goes
around has a very simple kind of
scheduling model but what if it becomes
overloaded
now they designed it to not become
overloaded but what if it does
yeah but ever said that oh it's okay
this will never happen that'll never
happen and they'll never happen yeah but
what if it does this is the code what
they did was they had a way of dropping
low priority tasks and they also had a
way that it would self reboot and do it
fast in a way that that would clear all
the all the unnecessary tasks but but
still retain navigation information
because as you know normally a reboot
doesn't do that it kind of clears
everything so therefore it could be a
fast reboot in other words it's okay to
reboot in-flight which is anybody
anybody if somebody told you that your
aircraft was going to reboot whilst it
was flying and you were on it you'd
normally be quite you know so this was
built this was built to do this now one
of the things that they had and it turns
out it's 1201 or 12 or to those two
error codes both you know notice start
executive overflow 12 or - I think
happened four times 12:01 happened once
it was on the descent now one of the
things they did during descent is they
just checked the rendezvous radar
because when they come back up and they
need the radar to find the command
module so they just checked it while
we're going down let's just check
standard routine thing that they're
going to do and it's not actually
necessary when you're landing you don't
need it but it's a check as you're going
in it turns out one of the things they
hadn't anticipated was a little bit of
incompatibility in the power supplies
and it turns out the power supply was
causing spurious signals that were being
interpreted as tasks that started
overloading the executive and this
started and this is what happened the
1202 era was basically it was this was
the system identifying there is a
problem appendix E and slow
restarting as necessary they saw a
patent 2i things Aldrin who actually
recognized the patents like wait a
minute this is coming up here on the
trans and it's this whole thing you know
we got a 1202 alarm go on no go they are
seconds away you know they're they're
gliding across the lunar surface
Armstrong's looking for somewhere to
land because the place they were
supposed to learn tonight
and boulders so he's trying to find a
spot to touch down they got this 1202
alarm and they're like oh and everybody
I feel you know keep it keep it chill
Neil Armstrong's heart rate on that got
up to something like 82 didn't they
looked at the telemetry they're like
this cool that's hiring the right people
yeah and yet Mission Control 1202 alarm
go or no-go and they're like you know
Eagle hold we're looking into that and a
minute later they like 1202 alarm again
and Mission Control by this point have
got the people who wrote the manual and
they're like what do we do with a
12-inch all I'm the like it's gonna be
fine and it just means the computer is
dumping its instructions and resetting
as long as they have controller all
right
you won't go they'll and they make
history this now this you can't you're
looking at going like well that's not
one of the standard photographs I've
ever seen yeah this is honestly the best
resolution we can find but this is a
unexpected 38 seconds after launch with
the second five engines burning 15 15
tons of fuel a second Apollo 12 got
struck by lightning twice and the entire
spacecraft basically starts responding
every warning light on the panel lights
up all of the instruments go dead the
Rockets are still firing because it's
quite hard to switch them off once they
got going so it is still climbing and
you know they're like you know this is
Apollo Houston you know we have a
problem basically everything has
suddenly stopped working and there was a
guy called John Aron who had worked on
the electrical systems that were flying
on this who was what's called a eek on
the environment electrical and
communications director he's in the
flight deck and he's like okay we have
never rehearsed for a lightning strike
but we have seen this telemetry pattern
before we've had one thing in one of our
training exercises where the people who
ran the simulations who were sadists
went switch off all the instruments and
see how they do with it and so he had
the kind of presence of mind to be like
alright we don't know what's cause this
looks like a lightning strike but let's
try the switching the main power to a
single SCE to auxiliary
so he said sc2 auxilary flight director
doesn't know what that is relays the
instruction they relay the stuff to the
ship one of the crew Alan beam who's the
lunar module pilot is like yeah I
remember that because it was in one of
the simulations flicks the switch
it makes its orbit they go into orbit
around the Earth they do a full check
out they're like yep you know what we
got struck by lightning twice but we're
okay
we're gonna go to the moon anyway and
you know I think did when they got to
the moon they played golf Pete Conrad
had a surveying rod and he got someone
to make him a little putter because they
want to see how far you could drive a
golf ball on the moon and just as an
interesting point Pete Conrad would have
been if you had the 1202 error not
worked out in favor they would have
bought at the mission and Pete Conrad
would have been the first man to Eris
effort of the moon
so we are we're almost out of time but
we're almost there but we're almost done
the level of dealing with the unexpected
went as far as this this memo basically
deals with what would have happened so
you can see the date July 18th the
landing was the 20th they launched on
16th in the event of a disaster here's a
speech that Nixon would deliver fate has
ordained men who went to the moon to
explore and peace will stay on the moon
to rest in peace and these brave man
Neil Armstrong and Edwin Aldrin know
there is no hope for their recovery but
they also know that there's hope for
mankind in their sacrifice and one of
the most interesting things is actually
that that lovely closing sentence right
the end they will be more by mother
earth that dead send two of her sons
into the unknown
love speech goes on but it's less
exciting after that this was one of so
said this was the speech in the event
that they landed but couldn't get back
off yeah so this was the speech if they
ended up with these two astronauts alive
on the surface of the Moon with no hope
of recovery
they had a speech for what would happen
if it exploded they had a speech for
what would happen if it crashed you know
expecting the unexpected all of these
things they had I mean I hadn't done a
huge amount of prep because they like oh
well they're halfway to the moon and we
should probably come up with something
just in case you know
so Capcom that's Charlie Duke on the
left he was I referred to him earlier on
mentioning Aldrin and Armstrong a prime
Tim that they were going to use the term
tranquility base Charlie Duke he was
Apollo 16 but Capcom is a very
particular role so yeah Capcom it comes
from the phrase caps your communicator
and they realized very early on that
within Mission Control
there are 30 or 40 people all of whom
are constantly they have their own
telemetry they have updates they have
advice they have questions can you check
this ask them to look at this I could do
that to minimize the risk of confusion
or conflicting orders they nominate one
person
Capcom the capsule communicator that is
the person who talks to the astronauts
you want to talk to the astronauts you
tell them they will either relay the
message or they will patch them through
to you you can talk to them directly
they are Houston they are Mission
Control from Houston we've had a problem
this is who Houston is this is who they
are talking to and you know that's a
lesson that applies in all sorts of
engineering situations you know getting
to work and you've got five different
people telling you five different things
are the most important fix this bug
ignore the bug fix this run that report
ship these designs don't ship those
designs move the button this way no move
the button that way Capcom is basically
like you know a really really good
product owner they take the input from
all the stakeholders and they make sure
that the implementation team are getting
one series of decisions that are not
being undermined and not being
challenged they control a channeler
communication between the stakeholders
and between the people who are actually
responsible for fulfilling the
objectives so there's a single voice but
also there's something else about this
one it's not just enough to have a
single voice that single voice has to be
competent and Trust it okay in other
words it's no good just simply the way
that many organizations do is like we're
going to nominate a product don't have
you ever been a product don't for now I
was something completely different but
suddenly you've parachuted in your
product owned that doesn't mean that you
won't do a good job but perhaps you're
not necessarily competent but also that
one of the biggest problems that people
have and get this Alliance as well how
do we control our product oh how do we
do this probably trust this is a really
simple case if we look as here's
somebody who trained with the people
who's communicating with and he is an
astronaut he's gonna set foot on the
moon you know I was they don't it's not
just these competent understands the
language and understands everything else
he is trusted implicitly already so in
other words too Capcom is not just
something you get random leads no get
randomly assigned there is definitely a
precondition to that so finally lift off
our eleventh item it's the user journey
that matters now we've talked at length
about spacecraft with names like Apollo
and Gemini and Mercury and lunar
excursion module z' and 1969 and co 105
or whatever it was the story that people
remember is not apollo or mercury or
gemini it is neil armstrong a human
being walking on the surface of the moon
when we create technological solutions
what we are trying to do is we are
trying to fulfill a human objective
we're trying to help somebody do
something the technology on its own is
not you know it doesn't solve any
problems until you put it in the hands
of a person and you say here you can use
this tool this product this framework
this compiler whatever it is that we're
creating you can use this and when we
get it right they take the things that
we have created and the outcome of that
is a compelling story it's a brilliant
product pitch you know it's a people
talking with their friends over drinks
at a conference like this ah you know I
used webstorm and it was amazing and it
was brilliant and it fixed this or
Visual Studio code was fantastic or have
you seen this thing that's coming out
and there's another while I was putting
this together I realized another
anniversary aerospace anniversary we
have this year 1969 was also the first
flight of Concorde and you know aviation
geeks are like Concorde a supersonic jet
liner but the story that Concorde sold
was you can leave home in New York in
the morning have meetings in London and
be home in time for bed
that was it so the people who flew once
it was the supersonic flight of a
lifetime no expense spared champagne
mark to break the sound barrier tell
your grandkids about it to the people
who flew it a lot and they existed they
were you know Concorde was about what
ten fifteen thousand dollars a ticket in
today's prices but for them the
it was nothing to do with the sound
barrier the story was about wake up in
America meetings in London home in time
to you know put your kids to bed
that was the compelling story and so
often when you know people you look at
the advertising campaigns of companies
now like like Apple and Samsung they're
not talking about megahertz and
processors in this they're showing happy
people doing things they're trying to
tell you human stories user journeys and
that's what they're sharing it doesn't
matter whether you're building software
tools or websites or you're trying to
take somebody to the moon and back it is
the user journey that matters if you
lose sight of that you just end up with
technology and the only time anyone
remembers the technology hands up who
can name a nuclear power station is it
Chernobyl we remember technology yeah
when it fails you know we want what we
do to be part of these compelling
narratives these may be historic mainly
just happy people at the end of the day
we're gonna deliver a footprint that's
you know you have to just make that a
little more exciting but ultimately that
is that is one of the things that you
that's one of the things that's all of
that technology disappears you something
realize that is somebody's footprint on
another 150 years ago that's still there
half a million people forty billion
dollars some of the most advanced you
know risky cutting-edge aviation
engineering ever the spacecraft are in
museums or burned up on re-entry or
somewhere at the bottom of the ocean the
footprint the human footprint is the
flag the flag is white because it can't
it turns out the flags bleach in direct
sunlight like that
so the concept of nation has disappeared
we have a human foot that's that's where
we get a white flag of surrender
so let's splashdown let's just recap
strategy vision roadmap make decisions
communicate them follow through on them
you know reinforce them be prepared to
revisit your own decisions but if you're
inspiring people to follow your lead
have a vision and stick to it get the
right people it's a case of there is
motivation you want people who have the
motivation to work this and it's not
always the stars it's too easy to be
distracted by the stars and the obvious
roles it is everybody approaches and
decisions consider the alternatives you
know there will be ways of solving the
thing you're trying to do which at first
sight you think we're not using PHP
don't be ridiculous why not do that give
them due consideration you know at that
early stage you cast that and that wide
open when you pick an approach go with
it decisions are necessary otherwise
analysis paralysis you will make no
progress follow through identify the
milestones identify the risks
demonstrate each risk intentionally and
in turn not just theoretically deliver
on it actually have something that
empirically demonstrates it naming
things matters Snoopy
gumdrop Charlie Brown word excel other
common English words that are under
Google aboard I saw our Hanselman Scott
Hanselman giving a talk last night where
he talked about Microsoft calling a
framework net and how nowadays they
would never do anything that stupid like
calling an editor code and how you know
it may mean things matters name so how
we develop a sense of attachment and
ownership to the systems and the
products that we build and we maintain
take the system's view it's really easy
to just focus in on the bit that you're
good at you'll discipline your favorite
thing your favorite tool it's much it's
part of something far far larger and
that's definitely that also relates to
the people connection but it's important
you need to understand that
in context standardization don't solve
the same problem twice solve the problem
once duplicate the solution you know
know that your backups are gonna work if
you have two of something test them both
but they should do the same thing same
solution two different places
do not end up with square pegs and round
holes and test and that means just
everything test creatively sometimes you
need to simulate the world that you are
shouldn't deploy into sometimes it's not
easy to say well what is it like with
millions of users simultaneously
well create something get creative it's
not standard it doesn't matter create it
what's the software equivalent of
hanging someone sideways and making them
run down a piece of plywood yeah that's
what got us to the moon expect the
unexpected you know have plans even
stuff that you is not on your golden
path stuff that is not going to happen
test for the negatives you know the old
joke where a software engineer is
testing a bar and they're like one beer
two beers soft drink yeah we're good to
go and a QA engineers like one beer two
beers a million beers minus five beers a
lizard the bar is ready to go they open
the bar customer walks in says where's
the toilet and the bar explodes
[Laughter]
anticipate things which are not part of
your plan if someone can find a way to
mess with your system they will one
voice got me a trusted voice you need
this whether this person is an architect
product owner customer representative
whatever it is they have to have that
idea that whatever the confusion that
happens on the other side the confusion
in the customer confusion in the
organization whatever it is there is one
voice one voice you can trust and they
and you listen to them liftoff
so the user journey that matters
whatever we're doing we're helping
people get somewhere somewhere physical
somewhere technical someone metaphorical
and if we do it right they're gonna tell
people a story with a smile on their
face thank you very much thank you very
much
[Applause]